okay so this person makes a statement
and then asks for our thoughts the
statement is animals seek and find
patterns whether they are there or not
this pattern is a t + agent issah t
birth birthdays - broom hmm
this pattern is ax t + agent issah t
berthed superstitions among humans give
it enough time other animals will to
inevitably adopt religions before
developing a [ __ ] meter that is like
our scientific method what are your
thoughts I think there's too much loaded
into the idea that superstitions
superstition is the pathological version
of something that is usually not
pathological it is the detection of
patterns whose explanation you don't
know but are nonetheless a useful
indicator of something you sure you mean
pathological it just seems a little
strong no I mean it okay I mean and I
don't maybe i don't mean it to have
connotations beyond that it is
maladaptive yeah lissa is the broken
version it's the broken version - ich
ins that become reified as as aphorisms
when they're wrong we call them
superstitions right and patterns that
occur for reasons you can't figure out
but nonetheless help you limit the
search area for something or something
something along those lines are usually
if 9 times in 10 what passes through
this machinery is productive and what is
I miss machinery no passes through the
whatever the proper of the intuition
component rather than the superstition
component 9 9 times out of 10 it helps
you one time out of ten it's purely
nonsense that's still a huge win so in
any case animals do have superstition
this has been demonstrated in chickens I
believe yeah that's where somebody
basically set up a conveyor belt on
which I think it was like rocks and corn
were sent down in a random sequence so
they used a random number generator to
figure out whether the next thing
the belt was gonna be a rock or corn and
patterns of course exists there that
don't mean anything you know a random
sequence will have little patterns in it
and the chickens would pick up
expectation which you could tell they
had by how long they looked based on
patterns that just happened to be in the
in the ya-ya misapprehension of pattern
that was actually noise misapprehension
of noise into pattern and then changing
future behavior based on that
[Music]